australia has reopened its international
border for the first time since the
start of the coronavirus pandemic
several states are now allowing fully
vaccinated citizens to freely enter the
country without quarantining for a in a
hotel for two weeks the first arrivals
touched down on monday there were
emotional scenes at sydney airport as
families reunited
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh
they've been waiting a long time to hug
their loved ones again
after months of video calls and missed
milestones these australians have
finally returned home
a little bit scary and exciting i've
come home to see my mom because she's
not well
so um
it's all anxious and excitement and i
love her heaps and i can't wait to see
her oh how long have you been away two
years oh man yeah it's been a long time
this is a big deal
we've been locked out and to finally
have this chance to come back it's just
amazing so
we're a bit um overwhelmed and we just
can't wait to see our family it's going
to be amazing
australia sealed its borders in march
2020 citizens wishing to return had to
overcome an array of hurdles from
gaining special entry permission to
forking out thousands of dollars in
hotel quarantine fees
but the states of victoria new south
wales and canberra have now vaccinated
more than 80 percent of their adult
populations deemed high enough to allow
quarantine free entry to citizens who
have also had the jab
for some it's too little too late
i'm fully vaccinated i've been
vaccinated for
um
months now like in australian citizen
and i haven't been able to go back into
my own country and i've been able to
travel to every other country except
australia and i haven't seen my dad in
two years and now he's very very sick so
it's like appalling how australia has
treated us
this is the first stage in a plan that
will eventually include international
workers and tourists as the country
adapts to living with the virus rather
than trying to eliminate it
but for now these returning citizens are
the lucky ones vaccination rates and
reopening plans vary from state to state
meaning some australians will still have
to wait a little longer to hold their
loved ones again
[Music]
dw reporter rochelle harrison plesso is
at sydney airport and sent us this
report
it's the end of so-called fortress
australia after more than one and a half
years or 583 days to be exact the
country has lifted its controversial
travel ban from today fully vaccinated
australians will no longer have to apply
for an exemption to travel overseas and
fully vaccinated australians can fly
into sydney and melbourne the country's
two largest cities without having to go
through hotel quarantine so as you can
imagine that has set the scene for some
emotional reunions and lots of relief
here today at sydney airport
it's good feels real good it's glad that
um the borders are re-opening and
life in a new normal can move forward
how does it feel to have your big
brother home good
i love it we have to get back to real
life
can't stay on the island all our lives
i'm heading over to washington dc
to see my daughter who i haven't seen
for two years so i'm pretty excited
about that
prime minister scott morrison recently
said it was time to give australians
their lives back and that's what it
feels like as the country slowly opens
up again some 45 000 australians are
stranded abroad and have registered as
wanting to come home since the pandemic
began well they are the top priority
these eased restrictions first applying
to them the government then hopes to
welcome back fully vaccinated skilled
workers and international students
before the end of the year finally
they'll be followed by international
tourists so the reopening is gradual and
cautious rochelle harrison pless dw
sydney
you